hey everybody Alexa right here and I am
here with Trent Custer's director on our
mellow and we are going to play we are
we're gonna play some some warring
animal cute games our mellow is a
strategy game yes it is it's a digital
board game really that's that's so you
can see the I'm the king here and all of
his like clans around him he's dying
he's dying up the rock this dark force
and so has one of the heroes of our
mellow we have got to save the king
essentially oh my gosh look at that bear
yeah we can we can see the bear so yes
we can play severe so these are the
heroes so you play as a hero from our
mellow and when I say save the king I
really mean save the kingdom because the
king he's finished either way so you've
got a you've choose one of these heroes
and you move into the world of our
mellow you quest out from your clan
grounds and you're trying to claim the
throne before all the other heroes on
the board so four players so we can
choose any one of these heroes I'm gonna
show off Barnaby today because this is
one of our new heroes we've been in
early access for a while but um we've
got four new heroes so we have brawn
River Barnaby and de Sasha so it will
show off Barnaby from the rubber clan
he's so cute
yeah he's a good'n that's for sure
alright so yeah we choose our hero then
we choose a ring and a ring this
dependent on the clan that you're with
so we'll choose that emerald ring and
then you get to choose a hero a meal and
these are sort of like your your loadout
ah so we'll choose wits because which is
gonna give us an extra card
okay we're ready to roll
so you have four heroes questing out to
basically save our mellow from this king
who's dying of this dark force called
the rot a little pom here I know it's
quite a quite a somber tale but it was
once a once a lovely Kingdom and I sure
I'm sure everything will be fine by the
end of the game I hope so it wasn't for
a while yeah almost five years now so we
started out of hours like you know just
working on it you know when we didn't
have our when we went on our day jobs
but then we got real up the Kickstarter
about two years ago we've been working
on a full-time sense so the first thing
you do in our mellow is you choose a
quest so and you can choose whether we
want like a treasure or we want to get a
follower to our party or a spirit stone
and they test different stats and things
like this this is sort of the backbone
of our game we just just pick one now
Barnaby's a little bit we've got some of
them good wits but we're not trying to
get a follower so we'll go with this one
here and this will give us the spymaster
if we pass this question well that's a
pretty animation yeah so all the cuts we
have are of a hundred cards in the game
they're all fully animated I actually
have over 120 cards in the game so we
have like some of these darker cards as
well where you yourself can gain the
rock the same stillness that the King
has which is sort of like our dark side
of the force
but yet we have spell cards trickery
cards which are like your Game of
Thrones style political plays and then
so these guys for example you can you
can send them in to a peril and you know
and then of course we have items so like
consumable items like potions and things
that you can equip to your to your
inventory and stuff like that so really
evoking those tabletop role-playing you
know that nostalgia that we have for
those those really cool things so yeah
this is our quest over here this is sort
of like the background of what we're
doing but this is the goal here this is
the king he's dying of the rock we can
see he's got one right at the moment
over there and he'll gain a right every
night and lose health every dawn and so
and his palace is protected by four
horrific perils basically which are like
the hardest dice tests in the game so if
you get through the perils and you can
face the king then
take him out there's a few ways to win
but get into that in a second so DX
based game like a like many other sort
of board games out there we think we
lean on a bunch of stuff from board
games and card games but we this is all
design from scratch you know there's
there's not many games out there like I
know so is that over there
this is a Kingsguard so these guys they
actually move from settlement to
settlement um basically protecting the
land of armello and keeping the peace so
with a Bane which we'll see in a while
spawns like these dark NPCs that we have
within the world creatures at the right
the mulch they'll hunt them down and
also if we step out of line as a hero
then we can get a bounty on our head the
King can put a bounty on her head and
the Kingsguard it's like right now his
pawns attacking him
so thanks God we'll take them down so
bronzer bronzer he's one of our new
heroes as well and he's a real wrecking
ball his hero powers that whenever he
cast a spell he gets a bonus to his fire
and so that's that big smash that you
saw just then he's a good bear solid
bear bear so here's another one of our
new heroes as well I'm so sure and this
is one of our original ones Mercurio so
there'll be eight heroes in the game
it's all having so it's a turn-based
game but I can also do things while this
is all happening so I could play these
cards I could you know cruise around the
map or I could even like look at what's
you know going on in people's hero
shelves and get a feel for the strategy
of what the other players are going for
it's a full day night cycle so here we
are there's the king doing his thing
okay so while I was talking before about
the ways to win this is one of the way
so these Spirit stones can spawn around
the world or
confinement detentions it's a Bane's
gonna attack the room now those spirit
stones if you collect four of those you
can actually try and cleanse the king
you kill him in the process but you save
the land of armello from the right it's
all it's not really you know it's a
bittersweet ending however whichever way
it goes so each tile has different what
do you call it effects as well so right
now you can see what sort of
semi-transparent that's because on
forests at night you're stealth so this
is one of the things you know being a
digital board game that we can really
lean into so Sasha the rat her hero
powers that she stopped at night so we
she's around here somewhere but we are
yeah yeah which is kind of terrifying as
well she's a she kicks a bit ass but
then you know if you walk into the swamp
it'll deal you a damage if we go on here
it'll heal us if we need it and we can
actually explore by going on to dungeon
and you know we might have a chance of
finding a treasure or a party member or
awakening a pain that we saw before so
I'll keep moving over here to this Sun
to this settlement of mine so why I
decide to do again like this with
animals that's a really good question
and there's a few reasons like one thing
animals cross a lot of cultural
boundaries so you know when you know
it's a lot of discussions at the moment
about representation in games and that's
something that's super important to us
and you know one of the ways to ensure
that a lot of people are including is it
include something Universal like animals
and then also even just from a narrative
perspective to like it's really easy if
we have like a the rat clan you can
imagine they're gonna be the sneaky ones
the bear can't bear clan can be the big
sort of slower you know pacifist and the
wolf clan or our fighters we can lean
into a lot of sort of conventions there
that have been around for hundreds of
years
fables and animals being
anthropomorphize than everything and
also it's just super cute it reminds me
of a little bit well it's funny that you
say that because um Blake Mitzi who's
you know one of my business partners at
league of geeks and also a key creative
on the game he was a major fan of red
wall growing up like read all the books
and everything and so it was his core
idea to do the animal thing when we got
together and we were like let's do a
digital board game you know to make an
adventure board game where you know you
quest out across the land and everything
like that and carve stories with your
friends he was like we've got to do the
animal thing you know we're gonna do
like a red wall inspired thing so that
was the first inspiration so what just
happened there is it's day now and so
the player with the highest prestige
which is a resource that you get from
doing heroic deeds and stuff can
actually advise the King on what today's
new Kings decoration will be which is
like a global rule change that affects
the board so just then he chose to
siphon to magic from all heroes and if
we don't have it then we would lose a
prestige and so that happens every game
and they're different or every door and
I should say and they're different every
single game but we also have so this
inventory here as well so you can see
like the rabbit oh sorry the rat and
saucer is equipped a couple of items
here and then of course as all I'll show
you all go into this so I'm about to
place a peril so this flag here means
that that's like a dice challenge that
we've got to go to encounter and
overcome so I'm actually gonna play
expendable okay sorry guys who play
expendables to it to bring its bring its
difficulty down and now I'm gonna go in
there let's see if I can get a shot oh
my gosh this animations so cute yeah
yeah he's great he's fantastic so I can
now as well I've got a match symbols
here so that's what we're trying to do
so in the right hand corner of the cards
you can see that we have those symbols
there so if I burn cards I can just
match those symbols if I have the cards
the symbols otherwise I roll dice in
those challenges okay we have dice
rolling cards everything heaps of stuff
room you know tabletop games really
bring about that vibe so this is a quest
this is the backbone of the game so this
is where we really zoom in on the hero's
personal journey and you know this this
happens in multiplayer as well like if
we're playing online multiplayer we've
designed this system so that it's fast
you can sort of just get through it and
people who just want to sort of power
game can just go okay well I want the
I'm gonna get the follower I just want
the staff and and it's out of the way
but it gives a player the chance to have
a sort of single-player role-playing
experience whilst being in a multiplayer
game that's really cool so right now we
you know the settlement of lines pride
is deathly quiet you can see members of
the Kingsguard forcing helpless
villagers into irons so we can fight the
Kingsguard and free the prisoners or we
can negotiate the prisoners release so
but both of these options will get a
bonus to our fights that and a prestige
but if we do this one we might get this
spy master card and you might join our
party let's do it let's try this one
let's try oh boy yeah so we don't have a
great chance but hey so the gods are not
prepared for real resistance and they
route in the face of your onslaught our
prisoner joins your cause as Thanks
so now we get this okay with you yeah
we've got enough to recruit oh so this
is this is the party system so basically
we can now recruit this follower and
they join our party and give us follower
cards are basically they're our follower
and treasure cards and they're the most
sought-after cards in the game and they
these really powerful abilities like for
example reveal all hero's quests so now
if we look at the board we'll be able to
see where the other heroes quests are
which will give us a major strategic
advantage of over them yeah so when you
say multiplayer is this local or online
or know locals coming later okay yeah so
that was one of the major requested
features that we had during our time in
early access but it just wasn't wasn't
possible it was something we never sort
of planned for and their design doesn't
really commit for it so we're hoping to
do that an update or an expansion but we
have full online multiplayer and
everything so this is this is this is
combat so we have we're we go again
we've kept the dice rolling so we can
burn cards again to guaranteed dice
results like I was do
before and then of course we use the
touchpad on the ps4 to roll your dice
and so it contributes to like attack or
defense you sort of Ted stop there
you're like so those beautiful combat
animations and everything in there it's
really just trying to I just wrote them
back them all oh boy he's very
territorial very intense very intense
bears was a key feature that we wanted
like right from the start was off on a
whiteboard and everything that earring I
mean he's got back Barnaby
yeah Barnaby is a bit of a little tank
like he doesn't really seem it but he's
he's got a bit of a muscle in him a
little tang yeah so weakened as well so
now like I was saying it's often because
we've completed our quest we know he
just played a card on to us is it this
is our mellow it's it's a brutal
protocol so we can have these guys as
well you see this little frog fisherman
over in the corner come to us from time
to time and basically bring up a quest
to be like hey I've got this new quest
for you in the land of armello and so we
can choose a new quest whenever they
they bring us rumors around the place so
it might be like a little pup saying
like a hero oh boy yeah so the land is
getting progressively progressively
darker sort of as the king is falling
into his illness I get to draw our cards
at return so a shield it's good we can
equip that one of these so insight
revolt so this is those sort of Game of
Thrones political style plays that I was
talking about and the more settlements
we are in the cheaper these cards become
cuz you have these Network settlements
people can help you out with favors and
then of course we have spells and again
like all 120 cards fully animated and
everything these cards are gorgeous yeah
we worked with a number of artists from
around the world so like illustrators
things like that and some for example
like this artist here you know only
graduated from university like maybe two
or three years ago or something like
that like incredibly talented when you
know working alongside and sort of push
to you know reach the limits of someone
like Adam Duncan who did this card you
know as being a new illustrator for
fifteen you know years or something like
that
yeah they've all meets Game of Thrones
yet red wall meets we like to say Game
of Thrones meet to come through Panda
that's that's how we take but then the
contraband is like really late in kind
of funny in this well the heaviness is
the Game of Thrones but we've got the
lighter edges like you know Barney he's
a bit of a Barnaby sorry he's a bit of a
crack up and then we have there's a
bunch of funny cards and stuff like that
as well so yeah but you can take that
you can just walk in there when you feel
you're powerful enough you can just walk
in there kick the door down and take on
the can or you can win by a prestige so
if the King dies of his illness
eventually and you have the highest
prestige you'll win or if you walk in
there with the four spirit stones you
know you can cleanse him and save the
land oh my god
mutual destruction yeah I'm a loser is a
pretty deadly place I love that that's
one in the moon the moon has the rabbit
face and as soon as the light is on it's
so cute it's good isn't it oh boy so
yeah another king separation so
fugitives unleashed all around our
mellow yeah we're coming out on PC Mac
and Linux so September 1st and also ps4
of course yeah ps4 coming out on the
first as well yeah all on the first
awesome well thank you for showing us
our mellow welcome you guys heard it
here September first grab it awesome
thank you